mom disowns him
meaning she is not going to acknowledge
him as her son she's choosing to abandon
him he ceases to exist to her and like
that
he's gone all because he married jenny
who is 30 years older than him yeah i
know we thought someone's mom came
around and she likes jenny now
[Music]
no she couldn't keep that act up for
long now that she knows samid and jenny
are husband and wife her true feelings
have emerged once again and they are
back with the vengeance
she's not tired of stressing herself out
oh the jenny and cement mama drama is
back y'all let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia i hope
you're feeling good about life today and
if you're not i hope you start to feel
better about it
i'm sending you love
through the screen
catch it
[Music]
in wild news i'm sure you've heard even
muhammad called it quits
that's not the shocking part it's not
even shocking that he cheated on her
it's messed up but i'm not shocked the
shocking part is that eve's been charged
with battery and assault charges she
denies i spoke to her rep too who
alleges that these charges are all a
part of this plan muhammad came up with
saying quote he created these false
accusations as a backup plan to get a u
visa a type of green card that lets
foreigners stay in the u.s if they've
been victims of a crime what type of
mess is that
people are trying it
if this turns out to be true i would
just be blown away by the fact that he
actually thought this would work
the audacity
trini asmr says quote i'm surprised
psychic sparkles didn't predict this was
coming during the tell-all jabri might
have to do a gut check y'all gonna last
y'all gonna last y'all ain't gonna last
my gut's usually right it's okay
smackles
this is why you don't talk loud about
things you don't know
all right a quick update before we look
at the biggest must-see moment from the
season 7 premiere of happily ever after
guess what y'all shaida and bilal are
back
charlie brown kick it
he's gonna fall out
and that is something i didn't see
coming after all the criticism below
received a part of me is looking forward
to seeing their journey continue and the
other side is like lord malicia
prepare yourself for all the hot takes
[Music]
that was so corny she wanted to
come back and
i wish it's my command so i actually
spoke with below and shada about
continuing their 90-day journey you
don't like her as much by the way really
i was gonna that was gonna be my next
question and we chatted about what's in
store for them plus more what is your
response i would say to viewers who
feel as if your husband is a narcissist
or a manipulative or he uses his money
to
have power over you
what do you say to those people who ride
for you
but they're also you know
downing your choice of a husband
it's it's difficult where do things
stand with you in shahidah now we have
to watch happy arab deck i want to get
ready to show you know and you will see
boundaries being created we got to talk
about the pregnancy journey
i know i know i know there is a long
list of things that my wife wants to do
and um and i'm just trying to fulfill
some of them before you know we bring
life into the world i think you will see
a lot of the anxiety possible happy
around that's gonna be so real make sure
you subscribe to entertainment tonight's
youtube channel so you don't miss the
full interview all right let's talk
submit and jenny
now we know smith's parents were against
he and jenny getting married from the
beginning because jenny is 30 years
older than him it got so bad that
sumit's mom
threatened to end her own life if cement
married ginny
yeah but on the most recent season of
the other way summit's mom seems to have
had a change of heart after 90 day mvp
in australia lead told her to stop being
selfish in meddling and submits
relationship
[Music]
we love you we love you so much
i felt like i had finally succeeded and
won over smith's family
do we have your blessings to marry we
are not going to stop you i'm not going
to
support you i understand
so i took the conversation i had with
them as approval to get married
well
it wasn't
after they got married i authorized
jenny and
sumit as husband and wife
[Applause]
was too afraid to tell his mom and dad
and when he had the chance during the
tell-all he backed out how nervous were
you
a hundred percent
now that they've been married for two
months he's decided that he has to tell
his parents because it's only a matter
of time before someone else does
today's a big deal
things not gonna be same
today i'm meeting my parents in order to
tell said that jenny and i are married
i'm risking my relationship with my
parents
but it's way far worse if i hired it
meanwhile jenny thinks all of this is a
bad idea and she's also feeling some
type of way that submit told her he
doesn't want her to talk when they meet
with his parents i'm supposed to just
sit there and be quiet and
you know take all the abuse we are just
discussing so why you need to prove
something that you always write i'm just
thinking what's gonna happen
just listen to me how come i always have
to listen to you don't listen to me ever
i'm listening to you
i know what's gonna happen you're like
oh well you know they're they're they'll
they'll accept it everything will be
fine you know that's not how it's going
to go but what does it mean i stopped
trying
they're my parents baby
this is serious business y'all for
context ever since they got married
they've been living in another apartment
across town because he and jenny are
afraid that someone's going to tell his
parents and they're going to come to the
house and try to take submit away
they've done it before and i know that
they're going gonna try and do it again
sheesh
so basically these two have been on the
run hiding and ducking as if they're
fugitives or something i don't
[Music]
care know my mom checked mainly corner
so clean the corners first
jenny and simek go back to their old
house for the meeting and once his mom
dad brother and sister-in-law arrive
things start off fairly nice his mom is
cordial toward ginny yes
tico
but it doesn't take long until she
starts talking about jenny to her face
[Music]
she's over here body shaming her
meanwhile their arms look the same to me
i hate to stoop to petty level but
damn
smith told me not to talk but he's not
saying anything at all
it's making me more nervous and it's
very awkward and i'm more and more
sweaty
jenny
after hearing his mom talk crap about
his wife samid finds the courage to
finally tell his family what they are
there for but jenny has to give him a
little nudge first
so
remember the last time you guys were
here yeah and we went and had that nice
talk in the park yes this is
well
what happened with that and nothing ever
became of it i never saw you guys again
after that
wait cement might have been on to
something with telling jenny not to talk
the moment she starts saying how she
feels his mom and dad's face go from
this
to this
video
smith's mom goes on to say that she and
his father will never be happy if submit
marries jenny
[Music]
and then submit just spits it out
and of course all hell breaks loose
so
this woman has said some of the worst
things to her son
[Music]
what is she so afraid of
really
letting go of her idea of how she
thought submits life should look a dream
she created in her mind based off of her
needs and wants not even considering
that he's a human being with his own
needs and wants
someone who deserves to experience a
life of his own i know my penis more
than anybody else no
so i know that they are worried about uh
society yeah there might be a part of
her that thinks she's protecting him but
this is the life he chose if anything at
this point she's hurting him and hurting
herself i know as humans we have that
animal instinct to stay part of the herd
but what she's basically saying is i
would rather have the world approve of
me aka people who will leave you high
and dry
then have a relationship with my son who
loves me deeply
what have we come to
will we allow the opinions of others to
matter so much
this is a prime example of how giving so
much power to people clearly makes your
life miserable
i doubt if she's going to be thinking
about having society's approval
on her deathbed
i would hope not
next week submits mom's breakdown
continues and jenny goes off on him for
how the meeting pans out
why doesn't everybody think it's okay
for me to stay here and take all this
abuse you are overreacting
i need to pamper yuna every time
whenever you get mad
gonna do what away from me
get away from me forever
you don't mean that jenny and she is
straight bucking at him yes we are back
to episodes ending on summit getting
yelled at by either his mom or jenny for
some reason that's how it tends to work
out for him hopefully he'll catch a
break
alright 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time
you